Một ngày 1, tổng thống Iran, ông Mà Surt, Paisy Skiyán, Trembo, Tehran sẽ khôi phục các cơ sở hạ nhân vội xương mạnh lớn hơn,
đông thời khẳng định nước này không theo đoổi vụ khí hát nhân. Phát biểu trong chuyên thăm tổ chức nặng lực
mệt tử Iran tại Thủ Đô Tehran, ông Paisy Skiyán, Nói, việc bị phá huy các nhà mấy và cơ sở hạ nhân không thể kiến Iran
dừng lại. Mà sẽ là sự thúc đời cho sự chở lại mẹ hơn. Tình bố được đưa ra, giữa lúc càng thẳng Iran
bị léo thang sau khi Washington không kết các cơ sở hạ nhân phó đầu, nát tan và is phát hàn của Iran hồi thẳng sở.
Chuyên quyền Mỹ luôn gà vục Tehran phát triển truy trình hạ nhân phục vụ mục đích quân sức trong khi Iran khẳng định
họ đậu của họ hoàn toàn mang tình dân sử. Tổng thống Mỹ đường đang trong gần đây cũng cần báo sẽ phát động chứa dịch tình công mới
nếu Tehran khôi phục các cơ sở từng bị phá huy. H hiện 2 nước đã trải qua năm vào đàn phát hạ nhân giản tiếp,
mà chưa đặt được kích quả của thế. Cuối thống người, nhé là các tối cà Iran ở lịch khảm yên này,
đã bắt bỏ khả nắng nối lễ hoạt động lối thoại về Mỹ, cho rằng việc lối thoại dễ áp lực và bị đe zua là vùng nghĩa,
đông thời khẳng định Iran sẽ không thoại hợp về chủ quyền và quyền phát triển nắng lực hạ nhân vi mục đích quà bình.